le lieu de notre rencontre doit être
tenu secret c'est à cette condition
seulement que nous sommes autorisés à
filmer
autour de cette table un groupe de
combattants étrangers venus prêter main
forte à l'armée ukrainienne
deux canadiens et un américain évoque
leur motivation
n'est plus président ukrainien a donné
son accord et a demandé à tous les
étrangers prêts à se battre de venir
aider l'ukraine à ma spécialité c'est le
sauvetage je suis infirmier s'il ya des
blessés des soldats difficile à
récupérer je serais plus qu'heureux de
leur sauver la vie de chat la drive ils
sont plus d'une trentaine venus du monde
entier mais peu d'entre eux acceptent
d'être filmé beaucoup ont un passé
militaire
j'ai servi dans les rangs de la 101e
aéroportée dans l'armée américaine je
regardais les informations sans arrêt
j'ai senti que j'avais des compétences
que je pouvais mettre à profit ici d'une
manière ou d'une autre concession peut
sauver une seule vie c'est ça qui compte
pour nous j'ai fait trois ans dans les
forces armées canadiennes en tant que
soldat d'infanterie je suis parti
pendant environ deux semaines ce n'était
pas la première fois en était un petit
peu plus un avion
il y avait il y avait de l'action ces
combattants viennent d'être intégrés
dans une unité de la garde nationale
ukrainienne a nié
sa forme un groupe assez autonome qui
peut se rendre sur la ligne de front si
on leur demande ils transportent les
morts et les blessés vers l'arrière
un groupe qui pourrait être déployé à
tout moment alors que les troupes russes
progress chaque jour un peu plus dans
l'est de l'ukraine